to keep up in the modern world of  driving the Land Rover brand has had to  adapt best known for making powerful gas  guzzlers in recent years it's tried its  hand at sharks it's run around and it  chases a younger demographic but one  feature has remained consistent being  able to conquer the land its latest  advance sees some smart 21st century  tech built into a classic car the SUV  makers rigged cameras on the grill and a  heads-up display on the windscreen to  create a virtual image of the terrain  called the transparent bonnet what lies  beneath the car appears projecting on  the hood offering the driver even more  visibility including what position the  front wheels are in while lamb brother  says the technology is pioneering it's  currently just a concept when a company  has no plans to release it as yet